[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم مشاهدينا في حصاد الليله معكم
حسن
جمول وفي الوقت الذي احدثكم فيه تقع احداث
وتتفاعل اخرى هذه صور مباشره من القدس
التي تبيت على وقع تصا في وتيره اقتحامات
المستوطنين للمسجد
الاقصى
وهذه مباشره صور من الخطوم التي شهدت
معارك ضاريه في انحاء مختلفه منها سقط على
اثرها قتلى مدنيون في قصف بمحيط القياده
العامه وفي مواضيع الحصاد لهذه
الليله يوم خامس من التصعيد بالاقصى نحو 1
و 500 مستوطن يقتحمون باحات المسجد
والسلطه الفلسطينيه تطالب بتدخل امريكي
ودولي عاجل والفصائل تحذر من تفجر الوضع
جراء الانتهاكات
الاسرائيليه وسط معارك ضاريه في انحاء
الخرطوم قتلى مدنيون في قصف بمحيط القياده
العامه الدعم السريع يشتبك للمره الاولى
مع مسلحين مساندين الجيش بولايه شرق
دارفور والخارجيه السودانيه تعلن رفضها
لمشروع قرار بريطاني في مجلس حقوق
الانسان زيلنسكي ييقول ان الهجوم المضاد
مستمر لكنه
بطيء ويتهم موسكو بمحاوله تجميد الصراع
ويؤكد ان الدعم الغربيه سيمنعها من
ذلك وواشنطن تعلن نقل ذخيره ايران مصادره
الى كيف لتخفيف نقص حاد يواجهه الجيش
الاوكراني بعد اتهامات للاتحاد الاوروبي
وفرنسا بالانحياز الى ارمينيا الرئيس
الاذربيجاني يقرر عدم المشاركه في محادثات
غرناطه الخماسيه باريس تجدد التزامها
بتزويد اريفان باسلحه دفاعيه ورئيس
الوزراء الارميني يؤكد استعداده
لتوقيع اتفاقيه
سلام في لقائنا اليومي قبل الحصاد على
منصاتنا الرسميه ناقشنا عزل مجلس النواب
الامريكي رئيسه كيفن ماكارثي وذلك لاول
مره في تاريخ المجلس والبلاد والتداعيات
المحتمله لهذه الخطوه لاستطلاع ارائكم
بشان هذا الموضوع كنا قد طرحنا عليكم
السؤال التالي برايكم كيف سيؤثر عزل مجلس
النواب الامريكي رئيسه للمره الاولى في
تاريخ البلاد على الوضع السياسي الداخلي
في الولايات المتحده 40% توقعوا مزيدا من
الصراع بين الجمهوريين والديمقراطيين
بينما ذهب
60% من الاصوات باتجاه هيمنه متزايده
للرئيس الامريكي السابق دونالد ترامب على
الحزب الجمهوري هذا السؤال سيبقى مطروحا
على منصاتنا الرقميه ويمكنكم دخول صفحه
صفحه التصويت عبر مسح رمز كيو ار الظاهر
على الشاشه لقاؤنا على المنصات الرقميه
يتجدد يوميا ونتطرق خلاله لقضايا مستجده
ومتفاعل عربيا
ودوليا وتتابعون في الحصاد
ايضا ما مدى نجاح سياسه حزب المحافظين
البريطاني في وقف وصول طالب اللجوء سؤال
نبحث عن اجابته عبر تحليل البيانات
الرسميه والمقارنه بين الخطاب
[موسيقى]
والتطبيق البدايه من القدس التي شهدت يوما
خامسا من الاقتحامات للمسجد الاقصى حيث
اعلنت دائره الاوقاف الاسلاميه ان
1435 مستوطنا ومتطرف يهوديا اقتحموا باحات
المسجد الاقصى المبارك اليوم في خامس ايام
عيد العرش اليهودي تحت حمايه مشدده من
شرطه الاحتلال وقد قامت شرطه الاحتلال
باغلاق محاور وطرق رئيسيه في محيط البلده
القديمه في القدس لتامين وصول المستوطنين
الى الحرم
القدسي تسميها اسرائيل حريه عباده للجميع
لكنها فعليا حريه عباده لليهود فقط
فاقتحمت المستوطنين لباحات المسجد الاقصى
يمنع خلالها دخول المصلين الفلسطينيين
باستثناء عدد من كبار السن وعند الابواب
صلوات جماعيه تحديدا عند باب القطانين حيث
تحولت منذ بدء عيد العرش اليهودي الى طقوس
[تصفيق]
يوميه يجبر الفلسطينيون من اصحاب المحل
التجاري
على الانتظار حتى انتهاء هذه الطقوس ومنهم
من اثروا ابقاء محلهم مغلقه بالكامل تجنبا
لاعتداءات المستوطنين احنا عمالنا بنيجي
نفتح محلاتنا تم منعنا من فتح المحلات لحد
ما يخلص المستوطنين صلاه في سوق القطانين
يوميا
الصبح وحتى عندما يحين موعد صلاه الظهر لا
تفتح ابواب المسجد الاقصى بالكامل امام
الفلسطينيين هذا هو الوضع عند باب
القطانين احد ابواب المسجد الاقصى المبارك
شرطه الاحتلال تمنع اعدادا من الفلسطينيين
من الدخول الى المسجد لاداء صلاه الظهر
والمشهد يتكرر في كافه ابواب المسجد
الاقصى المبارك احنا جينا من الخليل عشان
نصلي في الاقصى ومش راضين يعدونا بحكوا
لنا يرجعوا يوم الاحد بعد العيد اه بعد
عيد اليهود طبعا ومش راضين يدخلونا فمش
عارفين شو يعني نسوي يعني رع على الخليل
واحنا مش داخلين على الاقصى يعني عن جد
الشي الشي
بوج بحكي لي انه احنا اللي بقرر مين بط
ومين
لا تصعيد اعتبره الفلسطينيون ترسيخا لما
حذروا منه طويلا وهو تقسيم المسجد زمانيا
بين اليهود
والمسلمين وتم تمكين المئات من المستوطنين
من اقتحام المسجد الاقصى المبارك في ذات
الوقت يتم منع العديد من المصلين من
الدخول الى المسجد لاداء الصلوات ويتم
ملاحقه الشباب والنساء داخل المسجد
واخراجهم الى خارج
المسجد انتهاكات واعتداءات استهدفت
الفلسطينيين ايضا في ازقه البلده القديمه
فخلال مسيراتهم الاحتفاليه وجه بعضهم ومن
بينهم اطفال شتائم للعرب وضد الرسول
الكريم صلى الله عليه
وسلم اعتداءات لم يسلم منها المسيحيون في
البلده القديمه اذ تكررت ظاهره بسق
المستوطنين على الحجاج وعلى الكنائس
والمقدسات المسيحيه ما دفع الهيئه
الاسلاميه المسيحيه لنصره القدس الى
مطالبه المجتمع الدولي ومجلس الكنائس
العالمي بالتدخل والدفاع عن الوجود
المسيحي في الاراضي المقدسه نجوان سمري
الجزيره القدس
المحتله في ردود الفعل على هذا التصعيد
حذرت السلطه الفلسطينيه من تداعيات
استمرار الاقتحامات
اقتحامات المستوطنين للمسجد الاقصى
واعتداءاتهم على المقدسات ورجال الدين
المسيحيين في البلده القديمه من القدس
المحتله من جهتها طالبت وزاره الخارجيه
الفلسطينيه في بيان اصدرته طلبت بتدخل
امريكي ودولي عاجل لوضع حد للاقتحامات
وممارسات المستوطنين كما دانت دائره
الاوقاف والقوى الاسلاميه والوطنيه ما
وصفته بالتصعيد الاسرائيلي وحذرت من انه
سيقود الى تفجير الموقف على نطاق
واسع وحذرت حركه حماس من اشعال حرب دينيه
في المنطقه نتيجه تصاعد وتيره الانتهاكات
والاعتداءات الاسرائيليه على الاقصى
والمقدسات وحمل القيادي في حركه حماس
اسماعيل رضوان حكومه الاحتلال المسؤوليه
عن تداعيات العدوان على المسجد الاقصى
وقد وجهت الخارجيه الاردنيه مذكره احتجاج
رسميه لاسرائيل بشان الانتهاكات في المسجد
الاقصى وحذرت من ان الاعتداءات المتواصله
على المقدسات تنذر بالمزيد من التصعيد
وتمثل اتجاها خطيرا يجب العمل على وقفه
فورا وقال المتحدث باسم الخارجيه الاردنيه
ان المذكره تضمنت التاكيد على وجوب امتثال
اسرائيل لالتزاماتها و للقانون الدولي
بشان مدينه القدس المحتله ومقدساتها
والامتناع عن اي اجراءات من شانها المساس
بحرمه هذه الاماكن من جانبها دانت
الخارجيه القطريه بشده اقتحام المسجد
الاقصى ورفض سلطات الاحتلال الاسرائيلي
حمايه
المقدسات ينضم الينا من الناصر الدكتور
سليم بريك الخبير في الشان الاسرائيلي
والمحاضر في العلوم السياسيه مرحبا بك
دكتور سليم ماذا تهدف اسرائيل من وراء
رعايتها لاقتحامات المستوطنين والمتطرفين
اليهود للمسجد
الاقصى مساء الخير حسن لك ولجميع
المشاهدين عمليا اسرائيل تشعر الان بانها
تستطيع من ناحيه قوتها في في المنطقه ان
تفرض ما لم تستطيع ان تفرضه في مفاوضات كم
في سنه ال 2000 اي انه تقسيم المسجد
الاقصى لتقسيم زمني نحن راينا مثلا
بعد المجزره في
الحرم الابراهيمي انه تم تقسيمه تقسيم
جغرافي والان هناك محاوله طبعا ل تقسيم
زمني في المسجد الاقصى الان الذي حدث في
الفتره الاخيره هو قيام حكومه متطرفه
فاشيه التي تستند على مجموعه من اليهود
عمليا هي مج مجموعه قليله في المجتمع
اليهودي ولكن هذه المجموعه تعتقد بانها
يجب ان تسرع مجيئه المسيح وهذا يجب ان
يكون بواسطه استفزاز العالم لذلك نحن نرى
اولا استفزاز المسلمين بواسطه هذه
الاجراءات التي تحدث في المسجد الاقصى
ونحن نرى هذا الاستفزاز ايضا ضد الشعب
المسيحي يعني ما كيف يبصقون على رجال
الدين المسيحيين او محاوله الاستيلاء على
كنييسه ستيلا مارس في حيفا وكل هذه
الاجراءات التي لم تكن يعني غير مسبوقه لم
تكن في الماضي وبالاساس لان هذه المجموعه
المتطرفه هي التي تحكم الدوله الان ولهذا
تشعر بانها تستطيع ان تفعل ما تشاء وخصوصا
ان الشعب الفلسطيني اصبح يعني لا احد يهتم
بشانه الا الاردن مثلا او قطر ولكن باقي
الدول طبعا قسم منها يهرول الى التطبيع مع
اسرائيل كل هذا يساعدها على هذه الاجراءات
اين تكمن خطوره التقسيم الزماني للمسجد
الاقصى
الخطوره تكمن بانه اولا يعني في هناك
اتفاق اوسلو الذي عمليا حي ميت او ميت حي
ولكن واحد من بنود اتفاقيات اوسلو ان كل
ما يحدث في شرقي القدس وبما في ذلك المسجد
الاقصى عمليا يجب ان يبقى ل للفاينل ستاتو
او الاتفاق النهائي الان اتفاقيات اصلو
عمليا انتهت نعم ولذلك اسرائيل تفرض ما
تريد على ارض الواقع وهذا امر خطير جدا
طالما ان الخلاف الاسرائيلي فلسطيني هو
خلاف وطني على على اراضي وعلى حقوق هذا
افضل بكثير من ان يتحول هذا الخلاف لخلاف
ديني لانه في هذه الحاله فعلا هذا سيكون
خطير جدا كمان للشعب الاسرائيلي وكمان
للشعب الفلسطيني ولذلك باعتقادي هذه
الحكومه بهذه التركيبه تشكل خطر حتى على
مواطني دوله اسرائيل وليس فقط على الشعب
الفلسطيني واهل شرق القدس طيب بالنظر الى
الى المواقف التي صدرت عن الفصائل
الفلسطينيه وعن السلطه
الوطنيه الفلسطينيه اي تداعيات منتظره
فيما لو استمرت هذه الاقتحامات علما ان
اليوم هو اليوم الخامس من من عيد
العرش الاخبار الجيده بانه ايه حتى نهايه
هذا الاسبوع سينتهي هذا العيد و نامل ان
لا تكون هناك عمليات تصعيد اضافيه ولكن
الاخبار السيئه ان ممكن ان يكون
هناك تصعيد وممكن ان تنزلق الامور لحرب
محدوده ربما مع حماس ولكن مع الاسف السلطه
الفلسطينيه اصبحت مغلوب على امرها يعني
اكثر ما تستطيع هو ان تستجدي العالم
والعالم لا يكترث يعني حتى الولايات
المتحده الان مشغوله في امورها الداخليه
الان هناك ازمه داخليه في الولايات
المتحده باعتقادي حتى عمليه الملف السعودي
الان سيزاع عن الطاوله وربما لهذا سيكون
تاثير على القضيه الفلسطينيه ولكن في
نهايه المطاف الفلسطينيين متروكين لوحدهم
فقط الاردن وقطر لا ادري ربما الجزائر
يهتم الان بما يحدث في مسجد الاقصى وشرقي
القدس واسرائيل تستغل هذه الفرصه تستغل
هذا الضعف لفرض الامر الواقع كما حدث في
امور اخرى في الماضي شكرا شكرا لك دكتور
سليم بريك الخبير في الشان الاسرائيلي
والمحاضر في العلوم السياسيه حدثنا من
الناصره
الى التطورات في السودان حيث افادت مصادر
محليه بان الجيش قصف بالطائرات والمدفعيه
مواقع تابعه للدعم السريع في محيط سلاح
المدرعات وحي المجاهدين جنوبي الخرطوم وقد
لقي ثلاثه مدنيين مصرعهم بسقوط قذائف
عشوائيه على حي امتداد ناصر المجاور واكدت
مصادر محل للجزيره وقوع اشتباك للمره
الاولى بين قوات الدعم السريع ومسلحين
مساندين للجيش في ولايه شرق دارفور سياسيا
اكدت وزاره الخارجيه السودانيه رفض
الخرطوم القاطع لمشروع القرار الذي قدمته
بريطانيا امام مجلس حقوق الانسان التابع
للامم المتحده في جنف لتقصي الانتهاكات في
السودان لا تهدا المواجهات في السودان الا
لتتجدد سريعا وعلى نحو اشد واوسع صباح
الاربعاء اغار سلاح الجو السوداني على
مواقع لقوات الدعم السريع في المناطق
المحيطه بسلاح المدرعات جنوبي الخرطوم
القصف الذي امتد الى حي المشاهدين شاركت
فيه ايضا مدفعيه الجيش السوداني ومن مكان
تمركزها في امدرمان اطلقت مدفعيه الجيش
قذائفها على اهداف للدعم السريع في
اتجاهات مختلفه من ولايه
الخرطوم مناطق وسط الخرطوم ومحيط القياده
العامه للجيش وحي القرن هزتها انفجارات
قويه حيث يتبادل الطرفان منذ نحو اسبوعين
القصف المدفعي في منطقه القياده العامه
تلك المواجهات خلفت ثلاثه قتلى مدنيين
بينهم امراه اثر سقوط قذائف عشوائيه على
حي امتداد ناصر المجاور شرقي الخرطوم بحسب
بيان لما يسمى لجان المقاومه في الحي
بعيدا عن الخرطوم اعلنت قوات الدعم السريع
انها هاجمت الفرقه الس 16س عش التابعه
للجيش السوداني في نيالا عاصمه ولايه جنوب
دارفور وتحدثت مصادر محليه للجزيره عن حشد
الدعم السريع قوات كبيره في محاوله
لاستكمال السيطره على نيالا اثر زياره قام
بها قبل يومين الرجل الثاني في قوات الدعم
السريع عبد الرحيم دجلو للمدينه
الاستراتيجيه وعلى الصعيد السياسي سجلت
الخرطوم موقف غضب جديد ازاء ما تعتبره
انحيازا في النزاع هذه المره في مواجهه
مشروع قرار طرحته بريطانيا امام مجلس حقوق
الانسان التابع للامم المتحده في جينيف
يقضي بارسال فريق من الخبراء لتقص
الانتهاكات الحقوقيه في السودان منذ بدايه
المواجهات منتصف نيسان ابريل الماضي
الخارجيه السودانيه اكدت رفضها مشروع
القرار البريطاني وبررت ذلك بانه يفتقد
الى الانصاف والموضوعيه حيث يساوي بين
الجيش ومن سمتها الميليشيا المتمرده مشروع
القرار الذي نال ايضا موافقه الولايات
المتحده والمانيا والنروج من المقرر ان
يطرح نهايه الاسبوع المقبل على مجلس حقوق
الانسان قبل انتهاء دورته
الخريفيه من جانبه قال العميد نبيل عبد
الله المتحدث باسم الجيش السوداني في
ايجاز صوتي ان قوات الدعم السريع قصفت
مسجدا ومركزا صحيا شمال بحري ما اوقع قتلى
واصابات في صفوف
المدنيين قامت اليوم مليشيا الدعم السريع
المحلوله المتمرده بقصف مسجد حاج سعد
بالسراب شمال بحري المركز الصحي الملحق
بالمسجد مما ادى الى استشهاد تسع مواطنين
وجرح 15 اخرين وهذا سلوك تكرر كثيرا منذ
بدايه هذا تمرد
المشؤوم واعلن المتحدث باسم الجيش
السوداني صد هجوم لقوات الدعم السريع على
الفرقه الساس عش مشات التابعه للجيش
بمدينه نيالا في ولايه غرب
دارفور دحر بفضل الله وتوفيقه ابطال
الفرقه 16 مشا منيال اليوم هجوما
[موسيقى]
غاشماً متسع على الصعيد الجغرافي يوما بعد
يوم الى ما ينذر هذا الامر التحيه لك
ابتداء و لمشاهدي قناه الجزيره واقول ان
قوات الدعم السريع وبعد ان غارت على
المباني القياده العامه للجيش في الخرطوم
مرارا وتكرارا خلال الفتره الماضيه سعيا
الى احتلالها وخفقت في في ذلك المزع رمت
بثقلها اليوم مره اخرى في في دارفور
وبالتحديد في مدينه نيالا حاضره ولايه
جنوب دارفور حث التي شهدت الهجوم الاعنف
من نوعه ل متمردي الدعم السريع على
حاميه المدينه سعيا الى استقلاله معلوم ان
هذه المنطقه تمثل الحاضنه
الاجتماعيه لقوات الدعم السريع وهي تسعى
الى احتلال مدينه نيال لرمزيتها بالنسبه
اليها اولا ولانها تمثل كبرى مدن الاقليم
ثانيا ولانها تستند الى مطار دولي ثالثا
ووضع المدينه تحت سيطره قوات الدعم السريع
سيمنحها فرصه لتلقي المدد على عبر هذا
المطار وللتوسع ربما اعلان حتى فصل دارفور
ا الجيش تمكن من سطح هذا الهجوم وبحسب ما
ذكر الناطق الرسمي فقد تكبدت القوات
المهاجمه خسائر كبيره رغم انها هاجمت
الحاميه للمره الاولى من اربعه محاور ام
ايضا ايضا المعارك استمرت في الخرطوم
بوتيره اخف واعتمدت في الاساس فيها قوات
الدعم السريع على قصف حاميات الجيش
بالمدفعيه ا اذا الدعم السريع الان يركز
على غرب دارفور ولايه غرب دارفور تحديدا
على مدينه نيالا كما تقول ولايه جنوب
دارفور نعم نعم
اي في حين انه الوضع في الخرطوم اصبح يعني
نوع من الستاتيكو الميداني ام لم يعد هناك
اي اخبار عن تقدم لطرف على اخر
والاشتباكات تحصل في نفس الاماكن منذ اشهر
نعم الجيش استراتيجيه واضحه ويكتفي
بالدفاع عن مقراته مع الاستعانه بفرق
العمل الخاص التي تخرج بتسليح نوعي و
باعداد بسيطه لتوقع خسائر في بين
المتمردين والاعتماد الاكبر يتم على
المدفعيه وعلى المسيرات وعلى لاح الطيان
على اعتبار ان الجيش يمتلك تفوقا نوعيا
على متمردي الدعم السريع بهذه الاسلحه
الجديد في الامر ان الضغط خف على سلاح
المدرعات الذي شهد
51 هجوما من قوات الدعم السريعه على حاميه
المدرعات في جنوب الخرطوم فشلت في تحقيق
هدفها تحول الامر الى القياده ال لكن كل
ذلك من دون من دون ان يعلن عن سيطره اي
طرف بشكل واضح على على
مناطق اساسيه ومهمه دا
الخرطوم اسمح لي انتقل هنا الى موضوع
الانتهاكات الذي تقول الام المتحده انها
تحصل كنتيجه لهذه الحرب في السودان
لماذا رفض
السودان لجنه تقصي حقائق ومشروع قرار
بريطاني بهذا المعنى في مجلس حقوق الانسان
نعم الخارجيه السودانيه اصدرت بيانا علقت
فيه على مشروع القرار الذي تقدمت به
بريطانيا كح للقلم في مجلس حقوق الانسان
ورات ان ديباجه القرار اتت متحامل على
السودان وانها ساوت بين الجيش الوطني
ومليشيا متمرده عليه علاوه على انها ترى
ان السودان يستضيف مكتبا
متكاملا للمفوضيه الساميه لحقوق الانسان
وخبيرا معينا لمراقبه اوضحه الانسان في
السودان وايضا بعثه موجوده ضمن بحثه ثمس ا
بموجب القرار 1591 وبالتالي لا يوجد ما
يستدعي المزيد من التدخل الدولي سيما وان
السودان اقدم على تكوين لجنه وطنيه لرصد
انتهاكات وجرائم قوات الدعم السريعه التي
ارتكبتها هذه القوه المتمرده في السودان
ويرى السودان ان بريطانيا تسيء استخدام
وضعها كحامل للقلم في السودان وانها ظلت
تلاحق السودان بعقو قوا دوليه وتدخلات
امميه وانها تحاول الان ان تنقل الكره من
الامم من مجلس الامن حيث حاولت عبران
جولات الى مجلس حقوق الانسان كي تتمكن من
ادانه السودان وتمرير مشروع القرار الذي
تريد دكتور مزمل ابو القاسم الاكاديمي
والمحلل السياسي السوداني شكرا
لكك
[موسيقى]
c
الى اخر التطورات المتعلقه بحرب روسيا على
اوكرانيا حيث اعلنت القياده المركزيه
الامريكيه ان واشنطن نقلت اكثر من مليون
طلقه من الذخيره الايرانيه التي تمت
مصادرتها الى اوكرانيا واوضحت القياده
المركزيه في بيان ان هذه الذخائر صودرت في
ديسمبر من العام الماضي بعدما كانت موجهه
من الحرس الثوري الايراني الى الحوثيين في
اليمن واكدت القياده التزام واشنطن بالعمل
مع حلفائها وشركائها لمواجهه تدفق
المساعدات الايرانيه الفتاكه في المنطقه
بجميع الوسائل
المشروعه وكانت شبكه سي ان ان قد نقلت عن
مسؤولين امريكيين قولهم انه من المقرر ان
تعلن القياده الوسطى للقوات الامريكيه
سياسه نقل الاسلحه الايرانيه الى اوكرانيا
في الاسبوع الجاري واكدت هذه المصادر ان
الولايات المتحده ستنقل الاسلحه التي تم
الاستيلاء عليها من ايران الى اوكرانيا
لتخفيف نقص حاد يواجهه الجيش
الاوكراني من جانبه اكد الرئيس الاوكراني
اهميه الدعم الغربي مشيرا الى ان بلاده
تلمس دعم ال اليات المتحده في هذه الاوقات
الصعبه للغايه على حد تعبيره واضاف ان
موسكو تريد تجميد النزاع وهو ما لا يصب في
مصلحه اوكرانيا وقال لقناه تلفزيونيه
ايطاليه ان الهجوم المضاد سيستمر حتى ولو
ببطء مجرد بطء ام اكثر لا تكافئ انجازات
الهجوم الاوكراني المضاد حتى الان صخب
الدعايه التي سبقته والى يونيو الماضي
بدات اوكرانيا هجومها المضاد بهدف استعاده
الاراضي التي احتلتها روسيا منذ بدء الحرب
وذلك عبر خط مواجهه يمتد نحو 1000 كيل متر
بعد اربعه اشهر من بدء الهجوم المضاد يقول
الرئيس الاوكراني فلاديمير زيلينسكي ان
ذلك الهجوم يتقدم ولو ببطء هو يبعث بهذا
جاهدا رسائل طمانه لداعميه الغربيين وعلى
راسهم واشنطن كي لا يتراجع الدعم وتحديدا
العسكري بعد شهرين من بدئه قالت صحيفه
واشنطن بوست ان الهجوم الاوكراني المضاد
قد تجمد وفي الشهر التالي قال رئيس هيئه
الاركان الامريكيه السابق الجنرال مارك
ميلي ان القوات الاوكرانيه كانت حتى خلال
الصيف ابطا مما توقعت الولايات المتحده
متوقعا ان ينتهي الهجوم في غضون 30 الى 45
يوما اي عند اواخر اكتوبر الجاري بحد اقصى
بسبب التغيرات الجويه المتوقعه ما الذي
خيب امال الاوكرانيين في الهجوم الم ضد
قبل انطلاقه تحسب الروس ودشنوا على مدار
اشهر خنادق ومخابئ ومصائد دبابات وزرعوا
الف الالغام في طريق الهجوم الاوكراني قبل
وقوعه كما يشكو الاوكرانيين من رجحان
الكفه الجويه في غير صالحهم خاصه مع تاخر
امدادات مقاتلات اف 16 ولعلها تستعيد عن
ذلك التراجع بهجمات الطائرات المسيره
بالمقابل لعبت الدبابات الغربيه التي زودت
بها اوكرانيا دورا مهما في شن ضربات بعيده
المدى ضد خطوط الامداد الروسيه لكن حتى
هذه الدبابات ستعاقب اوحال الامطار
المرتقبه خلال اسابيع يبدو الدعم الغربي
وتحديدا الامريكي لاوكرانيا محفوفا
بالغموض ربما من اجل ذلك اجرى الرئيس
الامريكي يوم الثلاثاء الثالث من اكتوبر
اتصالا هاتفيا جماعيا بحلفائه في كل من
كندا والاتحاد الاوروبي لبحث ما وصفه
البيت الابيض بتنسيق الدعم المستمر
لاوكرانيا وذ قبل ساعات فقط من حديث
زيلينسكي عن التقدم البطيء للهجوم
[موسيقى]
المضاد مشاهدينا نتحول الان مباشره الى
نابلس حيث قوات الاحتلال الاسرائيلي تقتحم
المنطقه الشرقيه من المدينه لتامين محاوله
اقتحام قبر
يوسف اذا هذه الصور من نابلس
حيث التطورات هناك تشير
الى قيام قوات الاحتلال ب تامين محاوله
مستوطنين اقتحام قبر يوسف ولهذه الغايه
عمدت قوات الاحتلال الى
اقتحام المطقه الشرقيه من مدينه
نابلس معنا من نابلس سامي سامر خويره
الصحفيه من نابلس ليضعنا في صوره ما يجري
حاليا
سامر مساء الخيرات يعطيكم العافيه
تفضل والله الوضع خطير جدا هذه مره من
المرات الصعبه اللي بون فيها هذا الاقتحام
الاسرائيلي بهذا الشكل والاقتحام بدا مبكر
يعني عاده كان يبدا الاقتحام تقريبا
الساعه ممكن واحده بعد منتصف الليل او
الثانيه عش لكن نحن الان بنتحدى عن قبل
ساعه من الان بدا الاقتحام العسكري الموسع
للمنطقه الشرقيه لمدينه نابلس كمان الجيش
الاسرائيلي لم يعد يدخل من محور واحد فقط
وهو مثلا من جهه حاجز حوار العسكري جنوب
نابلس الى المنطقه الشرقيه او من حاجز بيت
فوريك في المنطقه الشرقيه باتجاه القبر
لكن اليوم من اكثر من محور مشاه قوات خاصه
تكون قد سبقتها هناك استعانه في كثير من
الاحيان بالجرافات الضخمه هناك ايضا
استعانه بيكون بطائرات الدرون الطائرات
الاستطلاعيه التي تكون تحلق على مستوى
منخفض وبالتالي انت تتحدث عن هجوم كبير
جدا تقديراتنا بما لا يقل عن 50 اليه
عسكريه لو كل اليه عسكريه فيها اربع او
خمس جنود نحن بنتحدى عن اكثر من 250 جندي
اسرائيلي دخلوا الى هذه المنطقه التي تعد
اكثر منطقه سكانيه مكتظه منطقه قريبه على
مخيم بلاطه للاجئين الفلسطينيين لا تبعد
اقل اكثر من 500 متر ايضا هي داخل منطقه
تسمى بلاطه البلد وقريبه جدا من منطقه
عسكر البلد وشارع عمان وبالتالي هذه
المنطقه اليوم تتعرض عمالها لعدوان كبير
العمليه لن تستغرق ع 10 دقائق او ربع ساعه
الان هي العمليه لن تنتهي قبل الفجر نن
بنتحدى يكون قد سبقتهم قوات خاصه بلماس
بلباس مدني وهناك الاخطر من كل ذلك هي
القناصه الذين يعتلون اسطح البنايات
العاليه وكل المخاوف من ارتقاء شهداء او
اصابات جراء القناص الذين يستهدفون الشبان
الذين لا يملكون سوى الحجاره والزجاجات
الفارغه والعبوات الناسفه محليه الصنع
التي يقوم برقها او تفجيرها في طريق عليات
الاحتلال الاسرائيلي دعنا نفصل يعني اكثر
في
المعلومات المهمه التي اوردتها عن هذا
الاقتحام هل وصلت قوات الاحتلال الى
المكان الذي تريد الوصول اليه من خلال هذا
الاقتحان في المنطقه الشرقيه لنابلس وصلت
قوات الاحتلال نعم وصلت نعم وصلت الى محيط
المنطقه هناك قبر او ضريح هو لاحد الاشخاص
الصالحين من عائله دويكات لكن الاحتلال
مصر ان هذا القبر يعود الى سيدنا يوسف
عليه السلام وبالتالي بات يسموه ضريح يوسف
المستوطنين زميلي حتى تعرف كل مكان كل
مكان تخيل في الضفه الغربيه في قبر قديم
في بيت مهجور في حجاره قديمه يعني بحاولوا
يسيطروا عليه بحجه انه هذا اعود لهم مثال
سريع جدا انا قريب جدا سكني قريب جدا على
منطقه الجبل الشمالي بتعرفوا نابلس جبلين
عيبال الشمالي وجرزيم الجنوبي نابلس بين
جبلين جبل عيبال في التوراه و جبل اللعنه
بالنسبه لهم هم لا يؤمنوا الا بقدس الجبل
الجنوبي لكن هذا الجبل عباد به بيت قديم
يعني مهدوم منطقه تسمى برناط تخيل انه
المستوطنين الان يسيطروا عليه وبالتالي
قبر يوسف وبرنا وكثير من المواقع هي يريد
المستوطنين ان يعودوا اليها ويستغلوا وجود
الحكومه الاسرائيليه وبالتالي الجيش هو
الذي يحميهم انا اريد ان اوصل ال هذه
النقطه التي اود ان
اسالك حولها الان قوات الاحتلال وصلت الى
ما تقول انه قبر يوسف قبر يوسف
نعم اريد ان انوه فقط الى الصور التي
نشاهدها يعني نحن نشاهد مواجهات حصلت مع
قوات هي ساحه حرب هي ساحه حرب بكل ما تحمل
الكلمه من معنى هذا الامر في كل مره يدخل
الجيش الاسرائيلي لا يمكن للشبان ان يقفوا
متفرجين تحت اي ظرف كان الان ما السيناريو
السيناريو المعتاد ان ان صارت الامور كما
كانت في المرات الماضيه الان خلال ساعه
تبدا حافلات المستوطنين بالدخول الى هذه
المنطقه بحمايه جيش الاحتلال الاسرائيلي
هذه الحافلات في ظل وجود عيد العرش
اليهودي احنا نتوقع انه لا تقل عن 20
حافله 20 حافله ب 50 شخص شوف اضرب الرقم
شوف كم انت بتتحدث عن كم كم العدد الهائل
من المصه الحلات مصفح يعني افهم منك افهم
منك وكانك اجبت على السؤال الذي اود ان
اطرحه الان قوات الاحتلال وصلت الى تلك
المنطقه المنطقه الشرقيه التي تقول ان
فيها قبر يوسف
و الان المستوطنون والمتطرفون لم يدخلوا
بعد يعني هي تحاول ان تؤمن المنطقه حتى
يدخل المستوطنون حتى الان المستوطنون لم
يدخلوا فقط قوات الاحتلال باليات العسكريه
هي التي دخلت وتمركزت في المنطقه الشرقيه
بنابلس صحيح صحيح 100% هذا السيناريو
المعتاد الجيش الاسرائيلي الان ماذا يفعل
يحاول جاهدا ان يدفع الشبان والمقاومين
الى ابعد مسافه ممكنه من مدخل الرئيسي
الشارع الرئيسي الذي يؤدي الى القبر
وبالتالي بالتالي يكون الجيش قد تواجد على
مسافه لا تقل عن خمسه كيلومترات من اقرب
حاجز عسكري اما حواره في الجنوب واما حاجز
بيت فوريك في الشمال وبعد ذلك تكون حافلات
المستوطنين قد قدمت واستعدت وتدخل تباعا
الى منطقه قبر يوسف بون الجيش بالعاميه
مامن المنطقه الطائرات الدرون بتراقب
القناصه الاسطح البنايات العاليه القوات
الخاصه اللي بالسيارات المدنيه والجيش
العسكري والجرافات فبالتالي هم حاولوا
يدفعوا الشبان الى مسافه بعيده جدا حتى
تستطيع هذه الحافلات ان تدخل وتؤدي بين
قرصين الصلوات التلموديه توقعاتنا ايضا ان
يكون هناك وزراء في حكومه نتنياهو ان
يكونوا مشاركين في هذا الاقتحام اليوم
الوزراء سواء بن كبير او غيره باركوا بكل
الصلوات التلموديه في قبر في القدس في
المسجد الاقصى في في الحرم الابراهيمي في
الخليل وفي كثير من المناطق ام نحن الان
نشاهد على الشاشه الوضع في نابلس قبل قليل
والان
ايضا جزء من الصوره يشير الى نابلس مباشره
الان واضح ان هناك نوع من من التوتر كما
كما هو واضح
لكن بعد ساحه الحرب التي ذكرتها والتي
نشاهدها في الجزء الايسر من الشاشه الان
من حيث انت تتواجد كيف هو الوضع وتحديدا
في المنطقه القريبه من تواجد قوات
الاحتلال بعد اقتحامها للمنطقه
الشرقيه غالبا العمليه العسكريه تتركز في
المنطقه الشرقيه من مدينه
نابلس وبقيه المدينه اكون صريح معك يعني
بتكون هادئه يعني انا الان اسكن في بيتي
بحدسك من بيتي مطل على المنطقه الغربيه
بشكل كامل هناك هدوء مطلق كما تسمع حتى
سيارات ما في بالشوارع الناس الناس معظمها
الان على الجزيره على الفضائيات على البث
المباشر على المواقع الاخباريه الكل
بيتابع الكل تقريبا بتابع في ناس ممكن ما
بتنام الليل وهي بتتبع شو اللي بصير لكن
هل هذا يعني انه بقيه المدينه في مامن لا
طبعا لا طبعا وما في منطقه في الضفه
الغربيه بطولها وعرضها شمالها وجنوبها في
مامن ممكن الجيش يدخل الان الى اي منطقه
اخرى طالما هو موجود في نابلس ممكن تكون
قوات اخرى تدخل من مناطق اخرى من مدينه
نابس كل المدينه هي محا صر بالحواجز
العسكريه الاسرائيليه يعني انا ابعيد عني
مسافه ما بتزيد عن كيلو متر واحد هناك
حاجز يسمى حاجز ال 17 الذي يوصل الى
المنطقه الشماليه حاجز المنطقه الغربيه
فبالتالي هل يدخل الجيش الى المدينه كلها
طبعا يدخل لمدينه كلها لكن تتركز العمليه
العسكريه قلت لك انت بتتحدث عن 40 50 اليه
عسكريه معناته عدد كبير جدا فبيكون كل
التركيز او الغالبيه العظمى من قوه الجيش
في المنطقه الشرقيه لتامين دخول
المستوطنين افضل سامر سنعود اليك وقلت
بانه بانتظار وصول حافلات المستوطنين وال
والمتطرفين نود ان نشير الى
ان بحسب كتائب شهداء الاقصى تقول ب انها
فجرت عبوه ناسفه استهدفت جرافه عسكر
بعبوه ناسفه شرق مدينه نابلس في اثناء
عمليه الاقتحام للمنطقه الشرقيه من
المدينه ستبقى معنا سامر وسنعود اليك لكن
سانتقل الى جفار البديري من رام الله
مراسله الجزيره والمعلومات المتوفره لديك
جفاره عن هذا الاقتحام
الجديد حسن حتى الان وفق الهلال الاحمر
الفلسطيني اصيب قبل قليل
من المتواجدين في المنطقه بقنبله غاز
بالراس وتم نقله الى احدى مستشفيات
المدينه رغم الصعوبه الكبيره التي تواجهت
طواقم الاسعاف بالوصول الى المنطقه كما هو
متوقع بالطبع حسن ما نشاهده هذه الليله في
نابلس ليس بالامر الجديد نحن على مدار
اشهر طويله ولنقل على الاقل كل اربعاء ايه
مع فجر الخميس كل اسبوعين نشاهد ذات
المشهد مستوطنون يريدون تاديه صوات
التلموديه فيما يسمونه بقبر يوسف وهو ليس
مقام يهودي وفق كل المؤرخين
والباحثين لكن قوات الاحتلال تؤمن
للمستوطنين الدخول الى هذه المنطقه التي
هي اصلا تقع تحت سيطره السلطه الفلسطينيه
بالكامل اي ان انها تقع في منطقه الف ولكن
المستوطنون يصرون على الوصول الى هذا
القبر واداء طقوسهم التلموديه بالطبع كان
متوقع هذه الليله ان يعود المستوطنون
ويقتحمون القبر في ما نراه خلال الايام
الماضيه من اقتحامات المستوطنين بالالاف
للمسجد الاقصى المبارك ل في القدس للحرم
الابراهيمي الشريف في الخليل للاحتفال
فيما يعرف بعيد العرش اليهودي ولكن في هذه
الليله كان هناك على سبيل المثال نقاش
طويل بين الوزير اليميني اتمار بن كفير
ومسؤولي الاجهزه الامنيه الاسرائيليه ان
ان كان ان كان يتمكن من اقتحام المسجد
الاقصى المبارك مع يعني ساعات فجر صباح
هذا اليوم بعد 20 دقيقه سندخل في يوم
الخميس ولكن السؤال هل ان لم يدخل
ولم تسمح له الاجهزه الامنيه الاسرائيليه
باقتحام المسجد الاقصى المبارك هل سيتوجه
الليله الى مقام قبر يوسف وهذا ما ما
رايناه خلال الاشهر الماضيه
واقتحم المسجد المقام قبر يوسف في نابلس
على الاقل مرتين منذ بدايه هذا العام
اضافه الى اعضاء كنيست من الاحزاب الدينيه
المتطرفه وبالتالي ان دخل بن كفير فهذا
معناه اجداد جهات والتصدي ل غلاه
المستوطنين الذين يقتحمون نابلس من الجهه
الشرقيه تحديدا واضح ان حتى بن كفير اقتحم
وشارك مع الالاف من المستوطنين باداء
رقصات وطقوس تلميه في الحرم الابراهيمي
الشريف في الخليل وهو الذي يعتبر ايضا
مكان مقدس جدا ولكنه معرض للتقسيم الزماني
والمكاني منذ عام
1994 الان هناك المقاومون على الارض
يتصدون لهجمات المستوطنين كتائب شهداء
الاقصى الذراع المسلح لحركه فتح اكدت انها
فجرت عبوه في جرافه تابعه لقوات الاحتلال
الاسرائيلي ايضا هناك فصائل اخرى س وكما
تعودنا خلال الساعه القادمه ستبدا
البيانات ل التاكيد على ان مقاومين يتبعون
لها او للكتائب المسلحه
التي تتواجد في شمال الضفه الغربيه نابلس
جنين تول الكرم بانها ستقوم بتفجير عبوات
اخرى ولكن حتى الان ما نراه على الارض ان
شبان يلقون الحجاره على قوات الاحتلال
ولكن الاعداد كبيره جدا للقوات التي
اقتحمت نابلس من الجهه الجنوبيه حاجز
حواره والتي اصلا يعني منطقه شواره تتعرض
لهجمات منذ عصر هذا اليوم بسبب المستوطنين
وايضا من منطقه بيت فوريك شمال مدينه
نابلس وبالتالي السباحه كامله
لمناطق الفلسطينيه وفق ما تؤكده السلطه
الفلسطينيه الفصائل كافه باختلاف اطيافها
اذا نحن امام تصاعد للوضع ولكن هو لا
يختلف عن اسابيع ماضيه للاقتحامات التي
ينفذها المستوطنون بحمايه قوات الاحتلال
لقبر يوسف اي فقط للتذكير واشرت الى الى
هذه النقطه ان تلك المنطقه التي تقول
اي يقول المتطرفون ان قبر يوسف يتواجد بها
هذه المنطقه هي مصنفه من المناطق الف التي
يفترض ان تكون امنيا
وا
اداريا بالكامل تحت سيطره السلطه الوطنيه
الفلسطينيه هذا صحيح ولكن واضح اننا نرى
كيف ان هناك تفاهمات سياسيه
كاتفاقية المصنفه الف اي التي تخضع
بالكامل للسيطره الفلسطينيه ولكن واضح ان
الاحتلال الاسرائيلي يرسل رسائل الى كل
الجهات بان هو لا يوجد خطوط حمراء لا يوجد
مناطق لا تخضع
للاحتلال الاسرائيلي عندما يقتحم الاحتلال
هو يقتحم حتى في وطح النهار كنا نرى حسن
خلال الاشهر الماضيه اقتحامات في عمق
مدينه جنين في قلب طول كرم مخيم نور شمس
الذي يتعرض
لاعتداءات وانتهاكات مخيفه عدد الشهداء
الكبير يكون حتى في يعني في وطح النهار
دون اي اعتبار للمواقف حتى السياسيه
وبالتالي ما يحدث الليله هو جزء من هذه
الاقتحامات
يعني كما نشاهد على الشاشه توجد احدى
الجرافات تقوم بهناك ايضا اطلاق
ل قنابل الغاز والمسيل للدموع كما هو واضح
في الشاشه وكذلك
هناك جرافه تعمل عاده ما الذي تقوم به هذه
الاليات بعد اقتحام قوات الاحتلال
بياتها العسكريه ووصولها الى المنطقه
المستهدفه ما الذي ما الذي تقوم به
الجرافات في في المناطق
الخلفيه الشبان الفلسطينيون يعني يعودون
ويتذكرون على على على ما يبدو وكما نرى من
خلال سنوات طويله من التصدي لقوات
الاحتلال الاسرائيلي بالعوده للوسائل
البدائيه التي كانوا يستخدمونها سواء في
الانتفاضه الاولى التي احتفل او احيا
الفلسطينيون ذكراها انتفاضه عام 87 والتي
عرفت بانتفاضه الحجاره ومن ثم انتفاضه
الاقصى في هذه الاثناء يقوم الشبان عاده
وقبيل الاقتحام باشعال اطارات السيارات
واشعال النار في حاويات القمامه هذهه تخرج
دخان اسود الاحتلال يعتبر ان ذلك
يعيق يعيق عمليه رصدهم للشبان او
للمقاومين وبالتالي استخدام الجرافات هو
بدايه لازاله هذه العوائق سواء التي لا
يمكنهم ان او تعيق عمليه رؤيتهم للمكان
ورصد كل شيء على الارض رغم مع وجود طائرات
مسيره رغم وجود الاجهزه الاستخباريه
والامنيه على الارض وفي الجو ولكن بدايه
هم يقومون بازاله هذه العوائق
الاطارات الحاويات كل ما يتواجد لدى
الشبان يك يقومون بحرقها وبالتالي هم ايضا
يزيلون لتمكين الحافلات التي ستاتي
للمستوطنين من المرور والعبور للوصول الى
قبر يوسف وهو الاقرب الى مخيمي بلاطه وسكر
بسهوله وبيسر شكرا لك جيفارا البديري
حدثتنا من رام الله ونعود مشاهدينا الى
نابلس مع الدكتور فريد ابو ظهير الاكاديمي
والمحلل
السياسي واستاذ الاعلان في جامعه النجاح
مرحبا بك دكتور فريد اذا المشهد اليوم
متكرر
ولكنه يعني باكثر من 50 اليه عسكريه يجري
الاقتحام وينتظر ايضا ان تكون هناك حافلات
اي كبيره وعديده للمستوطنين للوصول الى
الى قبر يوسف في اي سياق تضع استمرار
الاقتحامات
هذه ايه طبعا تعلم ان الاقتحامات الكبيره
تكون عاده لها مبررات ومسببات بالنسبه
للاحتلال اهمها هنا الاعياد اي هذا اقتحام
ليس اقتحام عادي وانما هو بمناسبه اعياد
اي يحتفل فيها مئات او الاف المستوطنين في
مناطق داخل الضفه الغربيه زي
مثلا المسجد الابراهيمي مثلا وقبر يوسف
وغيرها من الاماكن وطبعا المهمه الاساسيه
لدى قوات الاحتلال هي حمايه المستوطنين
ومنع اي اصابه لاي مستوطن وبالتالي يوسعون
دائره ال العمليه لكي يؤمنوا دخول
المستوطنين طبعا هذه الاجراءات كما تحدثت
زميلتنا جيبارا يعني تثبت تماما انه الشعب
الفلسطيني يدافع عن نفسه لا اكثر ولا اقل
يعني نحن لم يعني دائما يتهمون
الفلسطينيين انهم يستهدفون الاسرائيليين
لكن الاسرائيليين هم الذين يدخلون ويدمرون
ويقتلون ويطلقون النار هنا وهناك والحقيقه
الاجتياح بدا والتوغل بدا قبل حوالي
ساعتين ونصف يعني عندما دخلوا من منطقه
الطور الجبل الجنوبي اللي هو جبل جرزيم بق
قوات اسرائيليه ثم بدات دخول من المنطقه
الشرقيه حواره الى الى قبر يوسف فلذلك
يعني الاحتلال الحقيقه لا يقيم اي اعتبار
يعني الان هناك حديث عن تطبيع مع السعوديه
ولا يقيم اي اعتبار ولا اي اهميه لاي
محادثات او سياسات او تطبيع او غيره هم
يقومون بعمليات امنيه بمعزل تماما عن اي
ابعاد
سياسيه بمعزل عن اي ابعاد سياسيه لك لكن
ثمت ابعاد امنيه هامه وصول قوات الاحتلال
بهذا الكم من الجنود والاليات وانتظار
وصول الحافلات حافلات المستوطنين الى هذه
المنطقه على صعيد الامني
لعل للامر دلالات هامه في هذا في هذا
المجال لا شك اولا يعني من اهم الامور
التي يجب ان تؤخذ بالاعتبار ان الان
ال الاحتلال دوله الاحتلال محكومه من قبل
اليمنيين هذا كلام ثابت ويظهر بوضوح
بالسياسات والاجراءات التي تنفذها قوات
الاحتلال الان اليمين يحكم ب بكل قوه
ويفرض سياساته على دوله الاحتلال الامر
الثاني هو ان محاوله اخضاع الشعب
الفلسطيني لسياسات الاحتلال وتهميش دور
السلطه الفلسطينيه بالمطلق يعني هم لا
يرون ان هناك سلطه الفلسطينيه لا يرون ان
هناك شعب فلسطيني حتى ولذلك يتجهون باتجاه
الدول العربيه من اجل اقامه علاقات معهم
لكن هل ما تقوم به قوات الاحتلال هو
بالضبط يعني عمليه غرس و وتجذير الصراع
يعني يعني هم يقولون حلول سلميه يقولون
يجب ان يكون هناك هدوء ان تتوقف العمليات
ضد الاحتلال لكن هم من يشعلون نار ال
الصراع وهم من يغرسون
بذور المعركه والحرب هم يطيلون امد معركه
ال التحرير لفلسطين ولذلك يعني اذا كان
المقاومه الفلسطينيه احيانا لا تستطيع ان
تحرك الشعب الفلسطيني الاحتلال نفسه يحرك
الشعب الفلسطيني لانه ما يقوم بالاحتلال
يصيب كل مواطن فلسطيني في كل مكان في
فلسطين كل بيت الان مصاب اما بهناك شهداء
او اسرى
او جرحى او اقتحامات وا او ازلال على
الحواجز ف الاحتلال الاسرائيلي هو الذي
يزرع بذور ال الصراع و ويعمق في فلسطين
طيب اي تداعيات
اي يمكن ان تكون مرتقبه لما يحصل هذه
الليله في في نابلس تحديدا في المنطقه
الشرقيه
منها يعني نحن قلنا على قناه الجزيره اكثر
من مره ان ال اراده الشبان المقاومين
تزداد الحقيقه اي قوه بضروره التصدي
للاحتلال قد لا يكون التصدي في نفس اللحظه
التي يتم فيها الاقتحام وان كان هناك طبعا
تصدي لكن سنشهد كما شهدنا سابقا عمليات
هنا وهناك
توقع يعني اصابات مباشره
و وقويه في صفوف الاحتلال وهذا ما يثير
ويجن له جنون الاحتلال وتتحرك عندها
امريكا وبعض الحكومات الدوليه لكي تهدئ
الوضع و فرض شروط
الاسرائيليين الشعب الفلسطيني لا يمكن لا
يمكن هذا منطق التاريخ وليس منطقي انا
منطقه التاريخ لا يوجد شعب يرضى الاذلال
والقمع والقتل الى متى سيستمر هذا الامر
دعهم يعني يقومون بما يشاؤون لكن الشعب
الفلسطيني لا يمكن ان يستسلم وان يرفع
الرايه
البيضاء هناك سؤال دائما يعني
يطرح
عن
تمكن قوات الاحتلال ربما صحيح اننا نشاهد
هنا هؤلاء
الشبان وهم
يواجهون بما يستطيعون يواجهون اليات قوات
الاحتلال المقتحمه ولكن يعني استسهال قوات
الاحتلال دائما الدخول الى المناطق
الفلسطينيه حتى تلك المناطق المصنفه الف
ووصولها الى اهدافها وتمهيد طريق
للمستوطنين للاقتحام عن ماذا يعبر هذا
المشهد
دائما هذا المشهد يعبر عن شيء واحد ان
الاحتلال يريد ان يفعل ما يشاء دون مع
استسلام كامل للشعب الفلسطيني وهذا كلام
مستحيل ان يحدث لا يمكن ان تنفذ قوات
الاحتلال سياساتها في في فلسطين في الضفه
الغربيه بالذات بدون وجود معارضه فلسطينيه
لا يمكن هذا الكلام ان يحدث ال كما ذكر
زميلي سامر قبل قليل يعني الحواجز تغلق
المدن الخارج والداخل يتعرض للتفتيش
واحيانا الازلال والاعتقال هذا الكلام
يعني يزرع مزيد من الاصرار لدى الشعب
الفلسطيني كل افراد الشعب الفلسطيني على
ضروره مواجهه الاحتلال رغم ما يحدث حولنا
من
من تطبيع وغيره من من الاتفاقيات لكن هذا
الكلام الحقيقه لا يؤثر على المستوى
الداخلي في فلسطين شكرا لك دكتور فريد ابو
ظهير الاكاديمي والمحلل السياسي واستاذ
الاعلام في جامعه النجاح كنت معنا من
نابلس ونعود مشاهدينا الى الصحفي سامر
خويره الموجود ايضا في نابلس ليضعنا في
صوره اخر التطورات الحاصله مع هذا
الاقتحام الاسرائيلي الجديد للمنطقه
الشرقيه لنابلس بهدف تامين وصول
المستوطنين والمتطرفين الى ما يعرف بقبر
يوسف سامر
نعم خليني اضع الناس بصوره شيء انساني
اللي هي الاصابات احنا الان حسب بيان رسمي
صدر قبل اقل من دقيقه من الهلال الاحمر
الفلسطيني بقول هناك 70 اصابه اختناق
بالغاز 70 شخص اصيبوا باختناق بالغاز ليش
لانه الجيش الاسرائيلي بيضرب قنابل الغاز
المثيله للدموع اللي فيها الفلفل السام
على البيوت على البيوت على المنازل الناس
الناس نايمه الوقت متاخر الناس بكره عندها
مدارس عندها اشغال اللي ما قدر حقيقه يخرج
من بيته بده بده بده بالعميه يدير باله
على اولاده وعلى زوجته واذا عنده اب مريض
او ام مريضه او جهاز اكسجين بده يدير باله
عليهم بده يكون حاطط ادوات حمايه زميله
بسيطه بصل بصل عشان يش موه او ممكن يكون
موفر كمامات بسيطه لكن تخيل لما قنبله غاز
بتدخل داخل بيت شو بده يتصرف شو بده يعمل
بحاله فعندك 70 حاله اصابه اختناق بالغاز
انا يعني في كل مره ب صل ل300 شخص مصابين
بالغاز هذول الوضع خطير جدا انت برضه
بتحكي عمالك عن اصابات الان قبل قليل جراء
الرصاص المطاطي الجيش اللي بيستخدمه في
شخص اصيب ايضا براسه نقل الى المستشفى انت
بتتحدث عن ممكن يكون حالات ولاده لنساء
يعني اكثر من مره في سيدات بدهم يولدوا
الجيش بيمنع سيارات الاسعاف بتتحرك رح
يصدر بيانات وياكد انه لسه ممكن سياره
الاسعاف تتعرض لاطلاق نار ياما اصيبت
سيارات اعف للهلال الاحمر ولغاته الطبيه
برصاص المباشر وبالتالي الجيش الاسرائيلي
مثل ما ذكر الدكتور فريد ابو ظهير وزميلته
جيفاره انت انسى كل شيء سياسي حطه على
طرفه ما تسال عنه لانه الاحتلال مش في
حسابه مش حسابه لا السعوديه ولا الامارات
ولا كل الدول ولا السلطه ولا حد هو فقط
عنده مشروع احلالي ماشي فيه قدما في ظل
حكومه اسرائيليه قد لا تتكرر مره اخرى فهو
مام فرصه ممكن الناط بتتكرر بده يخلص هذا
المشروع باسرع وقت ممكن قبر يوسف
المستوطنين ما بدهم بس يدخلوا يصلوا فيه
اوعى تفكر بده يصلوا ويروحوا هم بيطالبوا
طلب لرجعت عنه بالبقاء بقولوا للجيش انت
ليش بتروح ليه بترد بتنسحب انت ظلك موجود
انت ليش بتنسحب نن بن ظلنا موجودين لولا
هو صعوبه توفير الحمايه الدائمه لهم لانه
برجع بقول منطقه مفض في مقاومين لكن في
مخطط رسمي وممكن يطبق بالعوده الى كثير من
المناطق اللي ممكن الجيش يبقى فيها ويصير
وجود دائم للمستوطنين عندك مثال سريع
مستوطنه حومش بين نابلس وجنينها شارون عام
2005 انت بتعرف انه من 2005 لليوم ممنوع
ولا فلسطيني يوصلها وهي الجيش منع حد
والمستوطنين
رجعوا الموضوع اخطر كثير
جدا ب 30 ثانيه فقط الان كيف هو الوضع
تحديدا هو الوضع حقيقه انه اللي بيرفع
الراس انه هول الشباب الصغار مستب سلين
الى اخر درجه ممكنه هيكم شفتوا
بالفيديوهات شو بين ايديهم قنبله محليه
الصنع ملتوف ضربوها على ه الجيش بدهم ياخر
باي باي طريقه كانت بده يقولوا له انه
دخولك للضفه ول نابلس مش نزه مش شيء بسيط
انت جاي تصلي او جاي انت بدك تتنزه لن
يكون نزهه لكن للمره المليون نحن امام خطر
دوله المستوطنين القادمه في الضفه نعم
اذاعه الجيش الاسرائيلي تؤكد احتراق جرافه
عسكريه اسرائيليه بعد القاء زجاجات حارقه
عليها في نابلس انتهت مشاهدينا جوله
الحصاد لهذه الليله